I worry to the point that someone's
reality in the online world could be
better than their reality outside of it
a few weeks ago I was playing Call of
Duty and this lad comes into our lobby
to play with us and he was leveled like
a thousand and me and my mates just
thought I bet you savage he got 20 kills
in the game this guyy is probably like a
15year old he has got a level of status
from playing video games that strangers
are giving him credit and then I was
thinking this is dangerous because he
probably gets more recognition more
compliments more credit from a video
game than he ever could in his life at
15 the way we're creating a world that
can help people especially men medicate
their primitive needs without the need
to leave their bedroom exist in society
even work in some respects why would I
work 40 hours and be potentially someone
of no significance doing this job
whereas I could have real significance
being World of Warcraft or wherever and
video games are only getting better
where there's more cooperation more
teamwork more strategy as we see even
gamification of things online being made
to the point to really tap into human
psychology